i was an atheist i decided i was an
atheist when i was 13 years old
and um the way that i made my own way to
believe in first of all a god and then
ultimately
a personal god was because of
because of the conscience right like i
had this voice inside me that
directs me to try to do good and avoid
evil and i had to
and it seemed to hint that there was an
objective moral order and i sensed when
i was
at odds with that objective moral order
and
then i had to ask what is the source of
that moral order and ultimately it
became that that's
there's a there's a god who is the lord
of that order um
now scientists might say well that's you
know
uh the voice of thousands of years of
evolutionary
uh kind of ingrained behavior sure
as a how answer or an answer to a how
question
or um it's your synapses firing your
brain
sure that's again a question an answer
to a how question
but it doesn't answer those why
questions which find the sort of
richest fullest answer in that in in god
that's actually the perfect segue then
for for the second question which is
is god reasonable and
as you may know i made a pro-god
argument in my last book as i was
defending liberalism
and what i found was this is where a lot
of liberals sort of get disjointed the
the bill maher
liberals let's say sort of get
completely out of whack when you say
anything
about belief um so i'll let you answer
your own question there
well lots of um uh religious people also
get out of whack in response to that
which is that the liberals will say that
um
religion is only a matter of feelings
and therefore is sort of irrational
and some religious people go along with
that um
and they will say yes my faith is just
purely based on
on revelation and it it'll be
unreasonable and it makes me do
unreasonable things at its most extreme
do you have radical islam
of that kind of view that says well god
tells me to kill the infidel and there's
no arguing with that
and so the chapter is an argument for
you know
basically the the uh classical proofs
for god
and for the the the specifically the
medieval mode of reason which i argue
was a more capacious
and generous account of reason that said
that not only
can you reason about you know what you
could see through demonstrative
knowledge i
i see certain changes in the seasons or
i
observe regular movements of the
heavenly bodies and that tells me
something
about them but also i can then reason
further beyond that
and not relying on revelation at all or
the bible or what have you just using my
natural reason
i would have to find some way to explain
what
why all this change happens so what what
is the ultimate
cause behind all of these and that
as as saint thomas famously concludes
each of his five proofs for the
existence of god
that's what people call god you know
right and so
it's it's a it's a it's a case really
for what's called um
natural theology you know what you can
learn about god not using
the bible but just using your uh human
reason
and the fact that this god would allow
you to know him by your reason
suggests that he's also a reasonable god
so a god who doesn't call you to
kill the infidels what do you think
about the sort of micro
verse macro argument when it comes to
this that you know i know plenty of
non-believers and atheists that are
perfectly
moral people and decent upstanding
citizens
but at a macro level at a societal level
it just simply
cannot work you actually get into this a
little bit later in the book so we'll
get there too but
that it just it doesn't scale basically
yeah i mean i mean first of all there's
an argument from just looking at history
that
some of the worst regimes in the human
history have been
the atheistic ones because if you remove
um some higher authority that that
checks human power
and say well man can do anything he
wants
that's an invitation to stalinism that's
an invitation that has been an
invitation to
the horrors of north korea and the
chinese communist party or what have you
um but more fundamentally i mean uh look
the
the people who are making claims
about what's good or what's moral um
in a way in saint thomas's terms they're
already arguing for god
because if there is if there's something
that's that's good then there must be
something that is the most
good and the that thing that you must
imagine is the most good is
has you know what is what people call
god because there are
these degrees of perfection so um
i think that when people say that in a
way it's an invitation to
god rather than a refutation did you
happen to see the clip that went viral a
couple weeks ago of jordan peterson
talking about god and belief with tucker
carlson
did you see that by any chance it's
probably on that on that show that
tucker carlson tonight i i love
it but i haven't seen that episode no
there's a really extraordinary clip i'll
i'll
gladly send it to you where jordan's
basically talking about belief in god
and he said that when he when he was
about 25 he decided
to tell the truth meaning for the
truth's sake that
no matter what the outcome of saying the
truth not that everything will be good
but it will be the best possible outcome
because you're putting order into the
world as opposed
to putting lies out there and he said
that that was the ultimate expression of
faith believing in truth
just for the purpose of truth and i
thought that was
as well explained as i had heard
basically
i agree i agree and um you know order is
the first law of the
of the cosmos and um you know my own
look i was an atheist i decided i was an
atheist when i was 13 years old
and um the way that i made my own way to
believe in first of all a god and then
ultimately
a personal god was because of
because of the conscience right like i
had this voice inside me that
directs me to try to do good and avoid
evil and i had to
and it seemed to hint that there was an
objective moral order and i sensed when
i was
at odds with that objective moral order
and
then i had to ask what is the source of
that moral order and ultimately
became that that's there's a there's a
god who is the lord of that order
um now scientists might say well that's
you know uh the voice of thousands of
years of evolutionary
uh uh kind of ingrained behavior sure
as a how answer or an answer to a how
question
or um it's your synapses firing your
brain
sure that's again a question an answer
to a how question
but it doesn't answer those why
questions which find the sort of
richest fullest answer in that in in god
right so that
basically that thing that sits behind us
all the time that sort of is your moral
compass that
that kind of led you there so that gets
us actually to question three quite
nicely why would
god want you to take a day off you mean
we're allowed to take days off still
i don't think many of us are and i i
live as harry to life as anyone where
i'm
constantly you know right now i have my
phone on airplane mode and that's making
me twitch
i can't tell what's happening um but the
chapter is really
a case for the sabbath um and then it's
told through the
point of view and life of rabbi abraham
joshua heschel
who was a great hasidic figure in the
mid-century and
he had obviously it escaped nazi germany
much of his family had perished in the
holocaust
and he comes to the united states and he
sees some of the same
restlessness that had disturbed him
about europe uh
in the first half of the 20th century
where um
as he saw it much of life was devoted to
making conquest in what he called the
realm of space the realm of space is the
realm of
geopolitical conquest it's the realm of
economic competition it's the realm of
doing better than your neighbor
and you know some of that is legitimate
those are important goods that you
should try to secure but he argued that
um that you also need to give some
do some time for the realm of well the
realm of time
which was the realm of the sabbath it's
the realm of the eternal where you
you actually declare peace on your
neighbor for a day you declare peace in
the economic competition
and you in doing that you find an inner
liberty because you're
you're setting aside all these kind of
material attachments that
define the rest of your life um and
i you know i argue in a in the chapter
that there's also kind of
setting aside all the religious
dimensions there's a kind of
temporal secular benefit through that in
the sense that
uh you know our lives we were told
getting rid of the sabbath
would be a source of liberation and in
practice what it meant it is liberation
it's liberation for the market
it's liberation for the corporation it's
not necessarily liberation for the
family it's not liberation for the
worker
and um and i should mention this is a
theme throughout the book that's
something
that tradition proposes and looks like a
restriction on our freedom and you're
like oh i don't want this
in fact once you lose it you realize
that restriction
was a source of freedom and
paradoxically the loss of the
restriction
makes us less free you're more you're at
the mercy of your boss
well as you may know i try not to tweet
on the weekends and i usually tweet a
goodbye
on fridays and you know i'll be back on
monday and ben shapiro made the point
you'd know that
jews have basically been doing this for
a couple thousand years
it's been it's been around for a while
this this relaxation
do you find that especially now because
of social media
that this is of particular importance to
to take the sabbath whether it
whether depending whether you're jewish
or christian or whatever whether it's
saturday or sunday or a whole weekend
do you think that the social media
component has really made this more
complex
well i mean i i absolutely think i mean
i see again i see it in my own life i
try to take the sabbath
for christians the sunday sabbath i i
try to take it seriously
um but there is that twitching like i
said and so there has to be
you have to impose discipline on your
your own life i mean
i favor certain restrictions like
limiting the as senator
hawley has proposed limiting the
infinite squirrel or what have you but
at the end of the day look at
you know you you've got to take
ownership of this and
and um there's so much to be gained from
turning everything off and not being a
slave to that ghostly blue glow
you know 24 7. if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about spirituality instead of non-stop
yelling check out our spirituality
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist they're
all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell